The Universe is made of matter.
98% of this matter (ignoring the dark matter)
is pure Hydrogen and Helium, but thankfully
billions of years ago supergiant stars fused
the hydrogen and helium into all the other
elements and then exploded them all over the
Universe and that’s where chemistry came
from.
These elements grouped together into a vast
array of different molecules, and these molecules
combined with each other in a stupendous number
of complicated ways.
Chemistry is the subject that studies this
matter in all of its forms and how it all
interacts.
It goes from simple atoms right through to
complex biological molecules like proteins
and DNA.
It is a huge, fascinating and complex subject,
and this video is all of that condensed.
Humans have had an interest in Chemistry for
a very long time, we wouldn’t be what we
are today if it was not for the chemical reaction
of fire.
We used this to develop other chemical techniques
from cooking food, making metal from ores
or making glass amongst many others.
Since then many advances of human civilisation
have been built on the back of advances in
chemistry like metal working, or manufacturing
fertiliser or making new materials and drugs.
Lets look at what falls under the umbrella
of chemistry.
First there is matter and all the different
things matter is made of.
At the very smallest scale we start with atoms
and the periodic table that organises all
the different types of atom, called chemical
elements.
Elements in each column have similar chemical
properties.
Atoms are made of protons and neutrons in
the nucleus with electrons surrounding them
and most of chemistry is due to how these
electrons behave.
By joining together atoms you get molecules
and different kinds of molecule are called
chemical compounds.
Chemical compounds usually have very different
chemical properties to the elements they are
made from.
Think about it, Hydrogen is very explody,
oxygen is very burny, but combine them into
H2O you get water, the least explody burny
thing around.
Compounds don’t have to be made of singe
molecules, many solids like metals or salts
have a crystal structure, made of repeating
groups of atoms called unit cells.
If you have several substances together you
have a mixture, like the air around you or
a cake.
Now lets move onto how atoms stick together
with the very important subject of bonding.
Atoms bond together in several different ways
where they reduce their combined energy by
stealing or sharing electrons, or moving them
into different configurations.
A universal rule in science is everything
is always trying to minimise their energy
and bonding is one way that atoms achieve
that.
Understanding how energy moves around in chemical
substances is vital to understand when reactions
will or will not happen.
For example wood won’t react with oxygen
to start burning spontaneously, but if you
give it enough energy to begin with it will.
Another example where energy is very important
is where you can speed up a reaction between
two other compounds by introducing a catalyst,
and the catalysts make it more energetically
favourable, and so speeds up the reaction.
Energy also determines when compounds will
exist in the different forms, solid, liquid
or gas.
Which form they will be found in comes from
the temperature that they are at and the pressure
that they are under.
The values vary for each material but in general
things are solid at low temperature and/or
high pressure, and gas at high temperature
and low pressure.
Another really interesting from of matter
is a plasma which is a where you rip electrons
off atoms in a gas to make them into ions,
this is what is used to make neon lights.
Chemical reactions form the core of chemistry:
which compounds react with each other, why
they react, and what is left over after a
reaction.
There are many different kinds of reaction
which can be categorised in different ways.
All of these reactions are governed by a set
of fundamental rules called chemical laws
the foundation of which is the conservation
of mass and energy which means that no matter
or energy is created or destroyed in a chemical
reaction, they just change to different forms.
Kinetics is the study of how fast reactions
happen and the things that control what the
reaction rates are.
A reaction where electrons are transferred
from one reactant to another is called a Oxidation-Reduction
reaction, or a redox reaction for short.
Oxidation means a loss of electrons from a
substance and reduction means the gain of
electrons and they have to happen together.
An example is sodium and chlorine, chlorine
is the reducing agent, and sodium is the oxidising
agent.
Another important property of substances is
their pH, whether they are an acid or a base.
There are several theories to model acid-base
reactions, but one way to think about it is
that acids are substances that have a hydrogen
ion ready to give up in a chemical reaction
and a base is a substance that takes a hydrogen
ion.
If there are a number of different chemical
compounds which can react with each other
back and forth.
There can be swings between one substance
and another.
Equilibrium is where the amount of each substance
is constant, even though a reaction may still
be taking place.
This can also happen in phases changes like
from solid to liquid or liquid to gas.
This is the study of equilibrium.
So those are the basics of chemistry.
Research in chemistry looks at how these rules
apply in different chemical systems.
So now I’m going to move on to look at the
different fields in chemistry.
Theoretical chemistry attempts to explain
the structures of atoms and molecules and
how they interact using mathematical methods.
It is very closely related to theoretical
physics and quantum chemistry, and often uses
techniques in computational chemistry where
atoms, molecules and reactions are simulated
in a computer.
Now, simulating the proper quantum behaviour
of anything more complicated than a hydrogen
atom is very difficult/impossible for multiple
bodies.
So many cutting edge techniques in computer
science are used to try and simulate molecules
and how they interact with each other.
In fact this is one of the most exciting applications
of quantum computers because they would be
able to directly simulate chemical systems,
and would help with things like discovering
novel materials and drugs and a whole lot
more.
Physical Chemistry studies chemical systems
in terms of their physics, so things like
energy, force, time, motion, thermodynamics,
quantum properties amongst others.
There are many sub-fields, like looking at
the electronic properties in Electrochemistry
which is important for developing better batteries
or Materials Science which is trying to create
materials with new properties like extreme
strength, durability or self-healing.
This is a critical problem with building Earth
based nuclear fusion reactors which are reliant
on new materials.
Analytical chemistry is like detective work,
you’ve got a sample of something and you
need to work out what it is made of, and the
amount of the different components.
Chemists have developed a huge array of techniques
to probe and measure different properties
of different materials.
Traditional techniques involve wet chemical
techniques, like precipitation which separates
compounds depending on what temperature they
evaporate.
There’s also a huge array of modern techniques
like chromatography where different compounds
move at different speeds through a solution
and so separate.
Or the many different kinds of spectroscopy,
that can detect materials by shining light
on them, or mass spectrometry where the materials
are flung though electric or magnetic fields
to separate them according to their masses.
And finally we get to the huge fields of Inorganic,
Organic and Biochemistry.
Organic and Biochemistry look at the chemistry
of living things and Inorganic chemistry looks
at everything else, although there is still
a large amount of crossover.
Most of the inorganic compounds that are studied
are man-made and a lot of the motivation is
to find chemicals with new properties that
can be used in the chemical industry and the
wider world.
In fact there are very few areas of human
endeavour where inorganic chemistry has not
been used in some way.
There is medicine and agriculture, special
fluids like detergents or emulsifiers, special
coatings, materials, pigments or fuels for
many industrial purposes.
Within chemical production itself catalysts
are very important as they speed up other
chemical reactions.
Inorganic chemistry also bleeds into materials
science making solids with novel crystal structures
like high temperature superconductors for
example.
The list is is endless.
Now between inorganic and organic chemistry
sits organometallic chemistry.
This looks at organic compounds chemical which
are bonded with a metal, and are typically
used in reactions in the chemical industry
often as catalysts.
Organic chemistry looks at the structure and
behaviour of the molecules of life which are
typically built from a small set of different
atoms: carbon, hydrogen, oxygen and nitrogen,
plus a few others.
Organic chemists also look at making new organic
compounds with useful properties.
Organic molecules all contain carbon and the
carbon hydrogen bond is the most common structure
in organic chemistry.
There are a huge number of applications of
organic chemistry in industry: fertilisers,
pesticides, lubricants, polymers and plastics.
In the consumer world there’s fragrances,
flavourings and preservatives, and of course
drugs in the pharmaceutical industry.
And finally, out of organic chemistry comes
biochemistry which studies the chemistry of
living organisms.
Biochemistry studies components that can be
inorganic, like water or minerals, but also
looks at the biggest and most complex molecules
like proteins, fats and DNA.
At the other end this field also blends into
molecular biology which looks in the finest
detail at how life arises out of the chemical
processes inside cells.
Within biochemistry there are four main classes
of molecules called biomolecules.
Carbohydrates are used for structures and
storing energy.
Lipids which make up fats.
Proteins, which are very large molecules made
from amino acids that have a huge array of
different functions in the body.
And nucleic acids that are used to convey
genetic information.
Research in biochemistry has had a huge impact
on medicine helping us understand infectious
and genetic diseases, improving organ and
tissue transplantations, working our what
is wrong with you with clinical diagnostics
and of course understanding nutrition: looking
at the functions of vitamins and minerals
in our body.
Biochemistry has also important for agriculture
studying soils, fertilisers and pest controls
and there’s many other applications too.
So that is my attempt to summarise all of
chemistry in about 12 minutes, no simple task
as it’s so incredibly complicated.
It has always amazed me that something so
complex as a human is built on a foundation
of a huge number of simple chemical reactions.
Your consciousness right now is a function
of the chemistry going on in your braincells
oxygen being passed from your blood, and sugars
being metabolised inside them.
Chemistry spans a huge mountain of complexity
from a single atom to the cells that keep
you alive, and I find it endlessly fascinating.
Like with all my other videos there’s a
poster available and so if you want to get
Otherwise thanks again for watching, and for
me, its back to the drawing board.